questo sono io e forse vi starete
chiedendo come ho fatto a finire in
questa situazione
ma facciamo un passo indietro
[Musica]
fa dj originals questo è il video
registrato più a cap della mia inter
esistenza probabilmente anche al buio
anno si sono accese le luci si accendono
mentre passato nel matrix ok ragazzi
allora sto andando da quel mattacchione
di film sostanzialmente lui oggi mi
propone un veicolo da guidare non so
niente a riguardo mi ha detto malati
facciamo sorpreso noi nel mentre
registriamo specifico solo che phil ha
detto il giorno prima che avremmo fatto
un video su una macchina d'epoca
ok ragazzi arrivare sono arrivato il
problema è che non so dove sia film
poi invece 26
davanti alla fermata forse siamo
[Musica]
il freddo ma penso di aver trovato fila
ma con le scemo sin dal tempo che al 38
è chiusa per il sito di casa un minuto
dall asd qua con sé una lambo vera
vaccini come macchina o cambiano no
secondo me è ok hai preso veramente per
il culo
grazie
lo sapevi tu lo sapevi
[Musica]
come la panca
sì questa è tutta una bracciata sembra
quello per sganciare un nuovissimo va
bene
si sente proprio motore con una foto di
ragazzi dai facciamo un video
da tutti i ragazzi venuti questa nuova
lamborghini io sono fa vigente vai vai
correnti per la macchina grazie pronte
per prenderla
tu lo sapevi da ieri da un mese sei
messo un mezzo organizza sta roba ok
allora andiamo in citylife
siamo arrivati citylife incredibilmente
0,2 secondi sembra un teletrasporto
caretta la facciamo la gara si è
svolta con una macchina migliore forse
potremmo
[Musica]
va bene
6 fottutamente bravo a mentire cioè non
vorrei mai a c'è la tua ragazza ecco
perché io
strano ragazzi iscritti al canale di
file che bisogna comprare lamborghini
[Musica]
ok facciamo il pieno 2.000 euro ragazzi
è ancora vivo è
giusto allora come ci si sente a essere
mister visti e parlati questa
lamborghini
quindi ragazzi adesso fa vj proverà la
besta tutto quando va bene ragazzi
allora mettiamo la prima
[Musica]
sono belle
va bene mamma se lo schianto
si è bellissima già usa quindi letterari
non ho mai visto una lamborghini andare
così piano
può intervenire possiamo
bene ok a posto abbiamo preso il
controllo di pin di milano nella maniera
più tamarra del mondo probabilmente io
con la residenza qual aperto oggi
pomeriggio però va bene
[Musica]
buongiorno ragazzi
mi chiedi che lavoro fa scudo studio è
stato scelto stata o ma che lavoro fai
20 corse dubai bravo bravo
[Musica]
se vuoi vai vai